alors les chiffres impairs un petit jeu
c'est avec chopin de big ben c'est très
simple je vais rencontrer des gens qui
font à chaque fois que quelqu'un gagne
un point il paraît qu'un cadeau d'accord
on y va c'est parti radi a amené moi
quelqu'un en émoi darmon si rihanna
revient à mon chéri bonjour pourquoi on
joue pour quoi vas-y de la pension et
vadim étoiles à allez c'est parti là
quoi gagner là quoi gagner la télé aller
la télé tu es prêt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
celui qui gagne le point avec la télé
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jouve pas de télé c'est parti et bien
mon chéri tu veux pas de télé au change
les brigades le propre toujours pas dit
vas-y mon chien et vas-y
[Musique]
attention du bois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toujours pas je rappelle à trois
galettes et toujours pas et n'ont
toujours pas mal
[Musique]
wuala
la série est ce que tu remets la télé en
jeu pour une trottinette et la télé
[Musique]
attention si tu perds pas comme ça si tu
perds tu perds tout
gargiulo lolo olala
est-ce que replonger pour la télé la
télé la console c'est par tous les vents
l'appel à consentir le vélo
mais l'entrée en super league on a
toujours la télé on a toujours à terry
norman chéri c'est moi qui sais que
c'est votre allée le déchet c'est la
dernière au japon la télé et le scooter
ses papiers malades 4 0
merci à laisser partir